équipe a décidé de rendre hommage aux
grandes stars et aux icônes de la pop
culture qui inondent instagram hashtag
gramounes on a refait les photos
regarder
iris millénaire c'est maxime déni de
réussite
emilie rattache aux skis j'espère je dis
bien regardez qu'est ce qu'elle est
belle à s'y méprendre que mokhtar
évidemment noté jennifer lopez sublime
jennifer lopez sur instagram
on est là c'est notre jean mimi qui
s'est collé une carnation
cet été les plus suivis et là encore on
saisit un physique pareil là que mokhtar
a développé la dernière vraiment ma
préférée c'est rihanna pareil qui est
très populaire sur les réseaux et l'on
pouvait entendre que maxime vignes pour
cette photo
le même cas
[Applaudissements]